boss do you follow soccer are you a
soccer guy yeah you know when the world
championship's coming to European yet
are you following the World Cup or no
yes okay did you were you following the
story about the uh uh Messi and the
coach from Netherlands like do you know
the story behind it the backstory of
what happened or no no no no are you
following it at all or no I saw
something about Messi let me tell you I
thought it was so freaking so so the so
the the the the match ends
Netherlands loses to Argentina I don't
know if you saw that or not yeah and
then he goes up and he celebrates right
in front of a uh uh what do you call it
right in front of uh the coach yeah uh
the coach of Netherlands Louis van Gaal
who was a legend in the in the soccer
World there's a legendary coach and he
goes to him and he says you talk too
much you didn't see that part no it's
pretty epic so he goes to say you talk
too much and everybody's there looking
at messages Messi typically doesn't have
a temper like this message been very
angry angry so apparently the story
behind Louis van Gaal is back in 2002
Van Gogh becomes the coach of Barcelona
and at that time they have this player
that comes in whose name is rickel me
who rickel me Van Gogh asked him to play
out of position Van Gogh Raquel says I'm
not going to play at a position anyways
he couldn't stand Raquel May and Rick
when he was to core go he would come up
and go like this okay so when Messi
scores the goal he goes right in front
of Van Gogh's bench and he goes like
this to him he's saying tell me because
prior to the game the coach Van Gogh
said if we go to a penalty shootout
we're going to beat him his week and he
says Messi doesn't play defense anyways
it was amazing uh to see how uh Messi
remembers the Revenge from 20 years ago
because rickel May was his captain and
he's seeking Vengeance for recalment
against the coach 20 years later 20
years later like an elephant yeah it's
like an elephant exactly so who do you
think is going to win are you following
any of it to see if it's going to be
France I think Argentina is playing uh
uh uh uh are they playing Morocco versus
Morocco Morocco Argentina against
Croatia Croatia France Morocco I mean
Morocco is doing really well right now
so I don't know you know it would be
cool they never got it right the Dutch
why the white we went three times to the
finals the team that went the most time
to the finals but never won yeah so they
they call Netherlands the greatest uh a
World Cup team ever that never won yeah
you guys they they put teams together
but it's like Stockton and Malone or
Charles Barkley but these guys listen
these guys are actually like they
deserve to have one and it's
unfortunately you know in the world of
competition man you can say these are
all you want but you know it's whoever
takes it yep and in soccer it's not
necessarily the best team that wins
because it's only one game it's a very
technical game there's luck involved
there's a lot of things involved in it
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because they
ain't nobody's saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]